[Music]
as always time for the press preview our
first look at the front pages as they
arrive in our inbox time to see what's
making the headlines with the daily
mails consultant editor andrew pearce
and the daily mirrors associate editor
kev mcguire got maguire they will be
with us uh from now until just before
midnight to those two in just a second
but let's take you through the front
pages that we have here's the guardian
it leads with the state of emergency
declared in ukraine and the u.s
government warning that russian forces
could invade very soon
the metro quotes the defense secretary
ben wallace's harsh words concerning the
russian president
putin's gone full tonto
with their chief reporter on the ground
in kiev the mirror declares
welcome to hell
meanwhile the financial times his word
of sanctions imposed on moscow by the
european union
the telegraph it takes a look at
forthcoming announcements about tax cuts
from the chancellor rishi sunak
i mean while the eye examines the
increasing burden of student loans on
university graduates
that is also the main story in the times
and crown jewels stolen is the headline
in the sun but don't panic not the real
ones uh just gems from a tv program
uh just a reminder that by scanning the
qr code that you will see on screen
right now and other points during the
program you can check out the front
pages of the papers while you watch me
andrew pierce and indeed kevin maguire
gentlemen lovely to have you on the
program um and let's let let's start
with the front of the ft shall we andrew
to you first i mean there have been
concerns that this was an inevitability
that there was going to be conflict the
only way it would seemingly have been
averted would by by turning off the
economic taps to uh to moscow we know
from the financial times in a number of
other papers
that there there is a real concern about
the way in which the british at least
have introduced sanctions
yeah um the british i mean the most
effective sanctions are of course have
been germany which has effectively told
putin he can't have his um pipeline his
gas pipeline uh it's it's on ice and in
fact perhaps it will never happen and i
hope it doesn't although that means
germany's somehow going to have to wean
itself off of a dependency on russian
gas and
their russian gas accounts nearly 40 50
percent of their supply but in britain
we've targeted five banks and three
individuals now the three individuals
that were targeted by british government
had already been uh sanctioned by the us
so i imagine whatever resources and
money they had they've already got well
out of london
so but boris johnson under pressure in
the commons today did say more sanctions
are coming um i don't know why more
weren't announced earlier but um i think
we've got to hope that they are coming
but the eu i think i'm often a critic of
the eu they've been it seems to me far
more proactive they targeted 27 or 29
individuals including some key fellas
key guys in putin's kitchen cabinet
chief of staff that sort of thing a
deputy prime minister then they're
getting right close up to putin and his
money and that's the way to hurt this
guy because he doesn't give a fig about
the russian people he cares about
himself and his reputation and he cares
about the uh the trying to recreate the
halcyon days of the old soviet union so
he doesn't care how many people are
murdered killed in this pointless
conflict
but what he does care about his money
and the people around him who prop him
up uh they've benefited very well
financially out of putin's corrupt
regime and
the pressure point will be for him if we
can get more and more of those people
financially embarrassed by sanctions
that puts putin in big big potential
political difficulty which is why i'm
hoping london's going to announce more
sanctions in the next 24 36 hours yeah
kevin well let's just stick with
sanctions just for a second i mean i
suspect you probably share andrew's
assessment you know if there are more
sanctions to come why have they not been
delivered now but but isn't part of the
problem that the prime minister and
others have is that there were
legislative changes that have been
promised for quite some time that would
have made somewhat less opaque the money
that is sloshing around the united
kingdom at the moment they haven't been
moved forward with and and so if you
don't know where the money is how do you
get it yeah and why not why why hasn't
there been greater urgency on it and
he's going to have to keep facing the
charge because the conservative party
have taken so much russian linked money
more than 2 million pounds hundred and
sixty thousand pounds for a russian
former uh foreign minister's wife uh to
play tennis with him back in in the day
because the european union's completely
out flanked the uk and the brexit
britain sanctions at the moment are
incredibly puny the three named
individuals the billionaire's going to
be sanctioned they've been on the
american list for
for years so they already face
restrictions and all have packed away
their money wherever it is but as andrew
says the
european union's come up with far harder
hitting 27 named people uh the chief of
staff and chief of staff the defense
minister heads of the army navy in the
air force uh two deputy prime ministers
all will have any assets that are
discovered frozen and not allowed to
travel around
the european union
area now these these things in
themselves may not stop putin but those
individuals will begin to wonder uh is
is this a good idea to
invade they're gonna carry the can to
some extent and how much are they
laundering money on behalf of putin
himself so
johnson i think has been a bit shaken by
the backlash particularly on the
conservative ranks because the official
opposition of course it will say let's
all be united it's gonna be critical but
you'll be shaken by the opposition with
his own party that his actions do not
match his rhetoric i mean andrew as we
take a look at the front page of the
guardian and their their headline
they're pretty stark state of emergency
in ukraine as u.s wants putin ready to
invade we have all been looking for what
the pretext for russian action may well
be and perhaps that came this evening at
the leaders of those separatist uh parts
of ukraine donetsk and uh donation
sorry for even forgotten it the two did
two parts to the east
they have asked for russian assistance
now
on that basis do you think we are as as
the united states is warning you know
past the point of no return now
well that's the most sinister
development isn't it also we know
there's some uh ships and amphibious
craft in the black sea uh and the
amphibious craft would be for one thing
to take troops on the ground in ukraine
but yeah the fact that these uh the
breakaway republics allegedly allegedly
have called for russian assistance to
repel these wicked ukrainians defending
their own territory is a a sure sign
that he's gearing up for something i
still hope and hope that he's gonna that
putin may at some point realize he's
boxing himself into a complete nightmare
here because it's gonna be a long and
bloody and bitter conflict ukrainians
are not going to roll over like they did
in 2014 they're much better armed and
i'm very reassured to hear the prime
minister here say today that we're going
to send even more armaments to ukraine
good
because we're not going to put any
troops on the ground and nor should we
we can't get sucked into that sort of
conflict uh but um but it is very
sinister neil and um you just have this
horrible feeling that when you turn the
radio on in the morning or the tv on in
the morning we're gonna hear that it
started yeah i have to admit i think i
will be going to bed with with one here
or one eye on my phone um take as though
kevin to the front of the the daily
mirror um
reporting from you you're fantastic i
have to say chief reporter andy lyons
welcome to hell is the warning but it's
that's not his assessment that is the
warning that the ukrainians are giving
to the russians
no absolutely look all media
organizations are now putting extra
people into ukraine i'm a great admirer
of reporters who at the drop of a hat
pack up and go going into what could
become our a war zone and put their uh
put their lives at risk in order to to
bring us the the news and the truth and
uh andy lyons is there now our defense
correspondent refuses also uh in ukraine
and it's the ukrainians saying look we
will fight we will we'll fight all the
way and the guardian had the picture of
putin laying a wreath at the
russian tomb of the unknown soldier
russians will die and possibly die in
large numbers now they may be able to
get tanks right to kiev very easily
cause huge destruction but occupying a
country is incredibly difficult as the
russians discovered in afghanistan
as the uk and the us also discovered in
afghanistan and in
you know in iraq and
in a way putin
is united ukraine against him he's he's
losing friends he's creating
uh enemies um they've mobilized uh their
reserves now in ukraine they've declared
that state of emergency they're saying
three million ukrainians who live in
russia should
should leave and you could see how in
one way he's driving ukraine into the
arms of nato it he could have the exact
opposite of his strategic goal and he
does look uh he looks deranged at the
moment when you when you see him
speaking you know we've watched him for
more than 20 years
in power but whatever
sanity and rationality was there early
on it seems to have gone
it's not just because he's at the end of
those large tables he's worried about
germs but even his own uh inner circle
look at him and you can see there
they're kind of frightened but there's
no respect there for him i mean briefly
andrew i mean is this that
on the basis of that assessment would
you describe him as you know totally
tonto
crackers around the twist he looks to he
does look deranged it's the wild staring
eyes and that rambling speech the other
day he should have really spoke to an
altar cue because at least he could have
stayed on message um you could see in
his eyes he's completely lost the plot
he's gone mad that's why some of the
comparisons i think with hitler are not
so misplaced of course it's we're not
talking about um
the the final solution the murder of six
million jews but hitler was was you
couldn't trust hitler he was mad he was
a megalomaniac uh and he you couldn't do
business with him nobody could do
business with him chamberlain was lied
to everybody was lighter and that's what
putin's done look how he utterly
humiliated president macron of france he
thinks he you know clever diplomacy
putin thinks he's just
he's just lost it completely and you
hope that some people in the russian
administration might just have the
courage to think we might have to take
control of this travis we need to head
toward we need to head to break so do
pause there we will be back immediately
afterwards uh where we'll be discussing
the fact that there is no subject to
taxing for andrew and kevin including
tax cuts we'll be discussing that after
the break
[Music]
welcome back to the press preview with
myself andrew and kevin um andrew let's
come to you first in front of the uh
telegraph rishi sunak will be publicly
committing to lowering taxes it's quite
something for a conservative chancellor
that he has to come out and say it
this is a huge speech by rishi sooner
the telegraph have decided to splash it
rather than go on ukraine i think they
probably got the detail of the speech
more than anybody else has got now it's
an admirable ambition for the chancellor
to say he's going to cut taxes but when
because we're just about to go into the
worst cost of living crisis probably for
30 years fuel bills are soaring petrol
absolutely going through the roof and
that's all going to be made much worse
by what's happening with ukraine and
russia and yet he's still going to say
he's going to put national insurance up
on april in april for employers and
employees by 1.25
and he's also freezing personal tax
allowances he's going to be lumbering
the country with the biggest tax burden
for 70 years so it's a bit rich for him
to say i'm a low tax chancellor he can't
blame these tax rises on the prime
minister he's the chance of the
exchequer it's his budget and then his
tax rises and this national insurance
increase is causing real unrest on the
tory benches which is why his popularity
in the latest conservative home league
table has seen him plummeting and kevin
the the front of the daily mirror this
is a very sad story um just tell us a
little bit for viewers not aware of on
the buses perhaps just a little bit too
young just tell us a little bit about it
yeah this is anna karen 85 a fantastic
uh actor died in a house fire in ilford
uh some people remember young people as
aunt sal and eastenders uh
andrew and i remember as olive in on the
buses which ran at the end of the 60s
early 70s set in a london bus
depot and
she was a
clippy a bus conduct a bit put upon um
but always bounce to back and she was
she gave so many people huge laughs and
back in the days it was watched by tens
of millions
of people because of a fewer tv channels
so we all kind of watch the same but it
it's all from the tributes to her uh
just absolutely genuine because she was
really liked and loved but it was what a
tragedy ago in a fire very very sad
story um andrew kevin we will see you in
just a few minutes time